is ukraine they chant at the russian
soldiers
the southern city is the only one russia
has managed to fully occupy four weeks
into this war
we came here to demonstrate that kerson
is ukraine we will never give our land
to some occupiers now our problem is the
russians we will be here regardless of
the weather rain or snow we will stay
here to demonstrate that we're here and
we're fighting we will never
protests against the russian presence
here are taking place on a daily basis
on monday for the first time russian
soldiers used tear gas and fired into
the air we spoke to one activist who is
closely monitoring the situation
there is no information they were
shooting at people but they were
shooting in the air
one of the stun grenades exploded next
to one person and that person lost a lot
of blood
there is information that some of the
protesters were detained and taken away
russia took the city earlier this month
it has been spare destruction and there
is no fighting here but the people
refuse to accept this new reality
[Music]
the soldier tried to show outwardly that
they are calm but they are nervous and
they are trying to find some support
but no one has welcomed them no one is
collaborating with them the population
is treating them as if they are aliens
[Applause]
hassan is of a major strategic
importance to russia it controls the
water supply to crimea and also crucial
for crossing one of the main rivers
giving potential access to the south
western and northern fronts
it may be russia's first ukrainian city
to occupy but finding support among the
population is proving a difficult task
i came here to freedom square to express
my concern because the occupiers are
shelling our cities killing our people
this is the 21st century we are coming
together to defend our city
[Applause]
heroes do not die this man yells enemies
die
the truth is with us the people are with
us they chant
and an amplified message
is ukraine
[Music]
the national anthem is sung again and
again
[Music]
[Applause]
a message to the russian soldiers that
they are an occupying force
and even if they do manage to take
control and hold more land it looks like
it will be nearly impossible to control
the people
stephanie decker al-jazeera in western
ukraine